this was filmed by an eyewitness moments
after a bomb ripped through a shia
mosque
it happened in northern afghanistan's
kunduz province a blast so powerful it
tore out wars
and killed many in what should have been
a place of peace and worship in the
islamic holy month of ramadan
many more were rushed to a local
hospital
we were worshiping outside
suddenly there was an explosion on the
second floor and people were thrown
everywhere many were killed and wounded
and we brought victims to the hospital
in khandus
afghanistan must try to prevent these
attacks so our people are not targeted
in the mosques schools and places of
worship
no group had claimed immediate
responsibility for the attack
taliban spokesman zaba hola mujahid
condemned the attack and says serious
efforts being made to arrest and punish
the perpetrators
afghanistan's isil affiliate had claimed
four bombings a day earlier
that included an attack on seducing
sharif less than 100 kilometers west
at least 12 people were killed
there has been a string of attacks by
isil-affiliated groups since the taliban
came to power last august
it has mostly targeted minority
communities including shia and hazara
setting major security challenges for
the taliban
one of the claims that the taliban made
was that they had practiced to
afghanistan unfortunately others used to
say that it wasn't peace that had
arrived it was just the absence of war
and that could only stay for so long the
idea is that the vacuum available the
failing state right now are all
contributors to the situation that are
being exploited by groups such as isk
back in kunduz a community left shaken
living under fear of more attacks
more about man the al jazeera